>> PARENTS ACROSS THE COUNTRY
ARE FIGHTING BACK AGAINST
CRITICAL RACE THEORY.
VIRGINIA EPICENTER OF THE
BATTLE.
MOMS AND DADS SPEAKING OUT AT
SCHOOL BOARD MEETINGS THIS WEEK.
THE WHITE HOUSE IS BRUSHING
ASIDE THEIR CONCERNS.
>> I DON'T THINK WE WOULD THINK
WE BELIEVE THAT EDUCATING THE
YOUTH AND NEXT GEN LEADERS,
FUTURE LEADERS ON SYSTEMIC
RACISM IS INDOCTRINATION OR
RESPONSIBLE.
MARTHA, IF NOT INDOCTRINATION,
WHY IS THERE SO MUCH
DISAGREEMENT ABOUT THIS AND WHY
IS THERE SO MUCH PASSIONATE
PUSHBACK FROM PARENTS OF ALL
RACES?
>> Martha: YOU KNOW, IT ALL
STEMS FROM 1619 PROJECT WHICH
STARTED IN THE "NEW YORK TIMES,"
WHICH PUT OUT A THEORY THAT 1619
IS THE ACTUAL FOUNDATION AND
ORIGINATION OF THE UNITED STATES
OF AMERICA AND THAT IT SHOULD
NOT BE LOOKED AT AS 1796.
A LOT HAS MADE WAY TO THE WHITE
HOUSE IN TERMS OF GRANTS AND
MONEY THEY GIVE TO DIFFERENT
EDUCATIONAL INSTITUTIONS ACROSS
THE COUNTRY.
THEY WOULD BE MORE FAVORED IF
THEY ARE TEACHING IT.
PEOPLE STARTED TO FIGURE OUT
WHAT IS IN THE DOCUMENTS.
I SPENT PART OF TODAY LOOKING AT
CRIM LUMS THAT INVOLVED CRITICAL
RACE THEORY, WHICH INCLUDE THE
IDEA IF YOU ARE WHITE AND YOU
THINK OR SAY THAT YOU ARE NOT
RACIST, IT ESSENTIALLY SIGNIFIES
THAT YOU ARE RACIST, YOU ARE
JUST NOT AWARE OF IT.
AND WE LOOKED AT WHAT HAPPENED
TO SHARON OSBORNE, SHE SAID I AM
NOT A RACIST, NEVER BEEN A
RACIST.
THEY SAID, YOU DON'T REALIZE YOU
ARE.
THE MORE PEOPLE UNDERSTAND THIS,
DOESN'T MATTER IF THEY ARE BLACK
OR WHITE, AS WE'VE SEEN IN THE
SCHOOL BOARD MEETINGS, THEY KNOW
THERE IS SOMETHING WRONG WITH
THIS, THEY DON'T WANT THE FUTURE
LEADERSHIP OF THIS COUNTRY TO BE
TAUGHT WE ARE A RACIST COUNTRY.
>> Kennedy: THAT IS WHAT THEY
ARE TEACHING, JESSE, IT AMOUNTS
TO PROPAGANDA, IN BIG CITIES
LIKE NEW YORK AND LOS ANGELES
AND D.C., HIGH SCHOOLERS ARE
WELL BELOW GRADE LEVEL IN TERMS
OF MATH AND ENGLISH PROFICIENCY,
WHY NOT TEACH THEM ACTUAL THINGS
THAT THEY NEED TO LEARN IN
SCHOOL LIKE HOW TO READ AND HOW
TO DO BASIC MATH?
>> Jesse: I'M ALL FOR THAT
KENNEDY.
LOOK AT WHAT CRITICAL RACE
THEORY IS, IT TELLS YOU THAT
WHITE PEOPLE ARE BAD AND THAT
WHITE PEOPLE ARE OPPRESSING
BLACK PEOPLE.
JUAN IS BLACK.
JUAN IS NOT OPPRESSED, ANYONE
THAT WEARS CUFF LINKS ARE NOT
OPPRESSED AND EVERY TIME I SEE
JUAN SHOW PICTURES OF HIS
FAMILY, EVERYONE LOOKS
BEAUTIFUL, LIKE THEY ARE HAVING
THE TIME OF THEIR LIVES 6789 I
LOOKED AT THE DETAILS.
IN SHIPLEY SCHOOL, OUTSIDE
PHILLY, NICE PREP SCHOOL, THEY
ARE TELLING PARENTS, NOT TO TELL
KIDS, YOU HAVE BEAUTIFUL, BLUE
EYES BECAUSE BLUE EYES RAISES TO
A STANDARD OF WHITE EUROPEAN
BEAUTY AND MARGINALIZES
BROWN-EYED PEOPLE.
YOU KNOW HOW I FEEL ABOUT THIS,
I DON'T THINK SCHOOLS SHOULD
GIVE HOMEWORK TO PARENTS AT ALL.
WE HAVE ENOUGH ON OUR PLATE N.
BUFFALO, BUFFALO IS TEACHING
KIDS, IF YOU ARE WHITE, YOU ARE
PARTICIPATING IN SYSTEMIC
RACISM.
THAT IS LIKE SAYING ALL PEOPLE
ARE -- THAT ARE WHITE ARE
RACISTS, WHEN WE KNOW THE REAL
PROBLEM IN BUFFALO ARE PEOPLE
BEING BILLS' FANS.
IN OREGON, THEY ARE TEACHING YOU
THAT MATH IS RACIST.
MATH IS JUST BORING N.
WASHINGTON, D.C., THEY ARE
TELLING YOU THAT THE PHRASE
"HARD WORK IS THE KEY TO
SUCCESS," IS A FORM OF WHITE
OPPRESSION.
YOU ASK ANY BLACK ATHLETE, BLACK
ENTREPRENEUR, BLACK ARTIST, THEY
WILL TELL YOU THE KEY TO SUCCESS
IS HARD WORK, I THINK 100%.
IT SOUNDS LIKE THIS CRITICAL
RACE THEORY IS A SCHEME FOR
WHITE LIBERALS TO SUBVERT BLACK
ACHIEVEMENT.
THAT IS WHAT THE REAL OPPRESSION
IS ABOUT.
BLACK PARENTS WANT THEIR KIDS TO
READ THE CLASSICS, TO LEARN MATH
AND ABSORB AMERICAN HISTORY SO
THEY CAN GET INTO COLLEGE.
ONCE YOU ARE IN COLLEGE, YOU CAN
LEARN ABOUT HOW EVERYBODY IS
RACIST, BUT YOU GOT TO GET INTO
COLLEGE FIRST.
>> Kennedy: YOU DO.
AND WITH SUCH HORRIBLE
STANDARDS, ESPECIALLY AFTER THE
PANDEMIC, JUAN, WHAT IS
SURPRISING TO ME AND I WOULD
NEVER TELL YOU, JUAN, ABOUT YOUR
EXPERIENCE AND HOW RACE HAS
AFFECTED YOUR WORLD VIEW AND
YOUR LIFE AND YOUR FEELINGS, BUT
I ALSO DON'T WANT TO HEAR THAT
FROM SOMEONE ELSE.
I DON'T WANT TO HEAR THAT MY
CHARACTERISTICS OR MY CHILDREN'S
CHARACTERISTICS SOMEHOW MAKE
THEM BAD PEOPLE.
I THINK THAT IS INCREDIBLY
UNFAIR AND WE HAVE ALL BEEN
RAISED THAT EQUALITY IS THE
ULTIMATE GOAL, BUT NOW THAT HAS
BEEN REPLACED WITH EQUITY AND
THIS AS "NEW YORK POST" POINTED
OUT IS A FORM OF MARXISM.
YOUR THOUGHTS?
>> Juan: WOW, IT IS HARD TO KNOW
WHERE TO START, KENNEDY.
I'LL START HERE.
I THINK TALKING ABOUT RACE MAKES
LOTS OF PEOPLE UNCOMFORTABLE.
I THINK SOME PEOPLE THINK IT
INVITES CHARGES OF GUILTY,
EMBARRASSMENT, RESENTMENT, THERE
IS DISAGREEMENT.
ALL OF THAT IS THERE.
BUT I DON'T THINK THAT HEALING
ON WHAT IS A MAJOR PROBLEM IN
AMERICAN SOCIETY, I DON'T THINK
HEALING CAN BEGIN UNLESS WE HAVE
THE CONVERSATION.
IF ALL OF YOU ARE SAYING THAT
SCHOOLCHILDREN ARE SUCH
SNOWFLAKES, YOU CAN'T TELL THEM
ABOUT AMERICAN HISTORY, YOU
CAN'T TELL THEM ABOUT SLAVERY,
YOU CAN'T TELL THEM ABOUT THE
RISE OF THE KLAN.
>> Kennedy: LET THEM READ "TO
KILL A MOCKINGBIRD."
>> Juan: THAT IS WHY THEY NEED
TO --
>> WE LEARNED THAT IN SCHOOL,
THAT IS NOT WHAT WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT.
>> Juan: HANG ON, MARTHA, WE
STILL HAVE STATES IN THE
COUNTRY, THEY BAN TEXTBOOKS THAT
TALK ABOUT SLAVERY IS THE CAUSE
FOR THE CIVIL WAR.
THEY DON'T WANT TO HEAR ABOUT
ONGOING RACISM IN THIS SOCIETY,
THEY SAY, YOU KNOW WHAT, THAT IS
INDOCTRINATION.
THAT IS NOT INDOCTRINATION, THAT
IS HISTORY, THAT IS HAVING YOUNG
PEOPLE DEAL HONESTLY WITH WHO WE
ARE AS AMERICANS.
INSTEAD, YOU GET, ESPECIALLY
FROM CONSERVATIVE POLITICIANS,
THEY SAY, OH, NO, WE WANT OUR
KIDS TO BE PROUD PATRIOTS AND
PROUD OF AMERICA.
YEAH, THEY CAN BE PROUD.
I'M A VERY PROUD AMERICAN, BUT
I'M ALSO VERY AWARE OF SOME OF
OUR DEFECTS, ESPECIALLY IN TERMS
OF THE ORIGINAL SIN OF RACISM
AND SLAVERY.
>> Kennedy: I UNDERSTAND THAT,
BUT DON'T TELL ME I'M A BAD
PERSON BECAUSE I'M WHITE WHEN MY
MOM CAME OVER ON A BOAT WITH ONE
SUITCASE FOR FIVE PEOPLE AND
WERE DISCRIMINATED AGAINST
ACTIVELY WHEN SHE GOT TO THE
UNITED STATES.
SHE GOT TWO ADVANCED DEGREES AND
BECAME AN ENGINEER AND IS
SELF-MADE BECAUSE OF THE
AMERICAN EXPERIENCE AND I'M
PROUD OF HER.
SO ANYWAY --
>> Juan: YOU SHOULD BE, SHE'S
GREAT.
>> Kennedy: GO AHEAD, WILL.
>> Will: I WELCOME THE
CONVERSATION, I DON'T THINK
HEALING CAN BE DONE UNTIL WE
LOOK AT EACH OTHER AS
INDIVIDUALS, INDIVIDUALS WHO ARE
JUDGED UPON MERIT, CHARACTER AND
SOUL, WHO THEY ARE AS
INDIVIDUALS.
THIS CURRICULUM ASKS US TO
DOUBLE DOWN ON SHALLOW
CHARACTERISTICS, SKIN COLOR
LEVEL.
JESSE LAYS OUT SEVERAL THINGS
THIS TEACHES.
IT TEACHES INDIVIDUALISM IS SIGN
OF WHITE SUPREMACY, I HAVE A
PROBLEM WITH THAT.
CURRENT TEACHING, WE WILL NOT
LOOK AT EACH OTHER AS
INDIVIDUALS, WE HAVE TO LOOK AT
EACH OTHER AS TRIBES, THAT IS
POISON, THAT IS RACI